[Music]
did you hear this about North Korea
handy what it depends on what it is okay
they love you know North North Korea
recently displayed several missiles they
this big parade to show off their
country's new military prowess and they
were showing off their missiles
well after studying footage from the
parade analysts are now saying that the
missiles are fakes this is a new story
yes they say that those are fake
missiles that the North Koreans were
showing in their parade now we actually
obtained footage of the parade and I
have to agree their missiles not very
convincing check it out
[Music]
you mean overnight or will be
[Applause]
[Music]
nothing I fear more than the dreaded
donkey yes